you'll come in
okay okay so
my stance moves in just like it always
says so
i have to have the ground vector i'm not
going to
step with my line of gravity
between it's the same ground vector
you're always using
the same it's a it'll be a both your
projection
so don't bring your center gravity over
and fall down
then don't stand on the tightrope your
feet will not be on the same type room
give some wick to your stance
and then don't clear the elbow you're
opening up
arm up
so i'm in some whip
and then oh i'm kicking this target
and this time drops this hand will be
hot not down here this is
so i'm not gonna block his strike i'm
not sitting here
i'm going to check the other hand
because i moved to that side
come on
okay let's try it okay so somehow we we
already got
close okay and he goes wow you see
that's my opening
just like if he's doing showman on this
is my opening
up not down uh
no so he's doing yoga man
that's not my opening this is my opinion
so we're in here and he does that hook
that's my
bone
so i do have my angle of deviation i'm
moving inside of it
but i'm not gonna move here
up and then hit my my opening already
happens
can add your eye slices so i'm going
this way with the eye slice
oh and i think so i get checked out
in here all right keep the check
here
nice more deviation
okay
drop your elbow you move off the circle
you're gonna move towards me
okay so when i do this he goes oh
my back foot is the vector foot
so i'm not just hitting him so the back
foot
is vectoring so i can displace his mask
okay so i don't want to hit him oh and
then
i'm sitting here i want him displaced so
we can
and the stick okay so right there
there's pressure you see the yard value
is changing
so he goes and i absorb then
i'm here then i'm gonna go around here
then
[Music]
oh
so don't block don't crack them
just keep going around the energy okay
[Music]
absorb
hey